[Music]
and Emily I'm gonna preface this with
saying I know that British people don't
like praise you've said it in a million
interviews but you're like stop saying
it just accept it twenty minutes in I
was like Julie who like I was that's
sacrilege I know it is and I I'm the
biggest fan of the movie but you were so
good in this and I know it takes like an
extreme amount of work to make that
performance look seamless so I want to
ask you Mary Poppins boot camp getting
ready to be read Evert ASCII ooh which
was harder I have to say I think Rita
vrataski was more intense and physically
so demanding so that's all I remember is
being in pain cheered up only by that
sweet little biscuit Tom Cruise I mean
you've had some great co-stars
I mean your lovely husband lin-manuel
Miranda Tom Cruise Daniel Kahlua I know
it just goes on and on but I will say
like talking about you know a quiet
place and now Mary Poppins I mean you've
had an incredible year in bathtubs so I
feel like this Mary Poppins bathtub
sequence will be the salv
to the horror that I brought to people's
bathrooms in quiet place I feel like I
did four bathtubs what Steven Spielberg
did for people swimming in the ocean you
and it's time to heal it all and make it
all right again thank you you for that I
will say this though I was in the room
for both I was at South by for that
premiere yeah I was at this one and so
tell me about the vibe comparing the two
cuz they're two separate vibes but the
crowds were both loving them I mean I
think that that's what I remember is
this sort of feeling of euphoria you
know on both nights I mean I think South
by with quiet place sticks out to me
because we didn't know what people would
think of it no idea this is that it was
I had seen it the producers had seen it
John had seen it and that's it and so we
drove there not knowing what the
reaction would be so that overwhelming
sort of stratospheric response where
people were almost
running up and smashing their chairs
they were so excited was really
overwhelming I remember just shaking I
mean we were both just shaking from it
and this one I know that a lot of people
had seen it before we went into it so I
knew the magic of it I knew the energy
the response it has been so joyful about
it so I felt this is a comic you know
it's that's totally understandable
um it's not a Christmas movie but it's
coming out and Christmas and it's kind
of like the gift that keeps on giving to
me
so at Rotten Tomatoes we voted it's a
wonderful life as our number one
Christmas movie of all time
do you agree it's number one so what's
your favorite scene so hard it's funny
you know when used to talk about
Christmas movies hilariously my father
every Christmas Eve whatcha Zulu which I
don't understand you know he's loves the
movie Zulu I feel like it's always on in
England at Christmas that's pretty
messed up like in America people are
watching It's a Wonderful Life and in
England Zulu is often on yeah Emily and
Ben told me it's also Mary Poppins as
well all right
[Music]
do what
[Music]
Lynne this movie I cannot talk enough
about it but let's talk about this fact
you are Disney Canon like from now until
forever oh there will be Puerto Rican
lamplighters walking through Disneyland
entertaining kids kids are gonna be able
to say that's my favorite Disney song
kick a little trip a little light
fantastic like you're their favorite
Disney character like is know well it
already makes me cry to think about all
of the like women of color who are
playing Moana in Disneyland's all over
the world Lee so the fact that you just
said Puerto Rican Lamplighter is like
it's it's there so with that being said
though you growing up what was your
Disney like what was the property what
was the song what what is your favorite
princess princess I'm gonna take Mary
I'm gonna take Mary Poppins Little
Mermaid and Moana off the list oh come
on I mean cuz you already in those yeah
well Little Mermaid was really big for
me like I think I know you named your
son Sebastian I did my son Sebastian but
I also think the fact that I think the
character of Sebastian he was such a
frustrated composer he was just trying
to get his show on until this girl
ruined it and and I related to that like
I was just you know I just thought he
was hilarious
and his music felt so contemporary to me
like when under-the-sea started I think
that's when my life in this business
started because I just it was the first
time I ever felt weightless in the movie
I was like - a musical number with the
ocean as your cast it just it like
exploded my imagination let me think of
a non um one of those I mean those were
really big in the Dan Canon another
Disney that was huge for me am I gonna
hold you to it you gave me a great night
but speaking of Sebastian what does he
think cuz I know he's your toughest
critic like the boy doesn't even like
Hamilton which I'm like how know it he's
warmed up to Hamilton okay yeah what do
you liked one he's good
what does he think about Mary Poppins he
hasn't seen the movie yet okay you'll
see it in a couple of weeks we're gonna
watch it in Washington Heights uptown
and I can't wait for him to see it
because he's seen so many of the moments
like to him Emily Blunt is the beautiful
lady who does a perfect Peppa Pig
impression from daddy's work so he has a
very different perspective on all this
greatness the other thing I was going to
say is you kind of been able to do
whatever you want like tick tick boom
a little mermaid curve I mean King Kurla
King Killer Chronicle Star Wars anything
that you want to do what is the place
where you want to go next to tell
stories where do you want to go if I
could like summon some Mary Poppins
magic and make it happen
uh-huh well I mean I'm glad you brought
up tick tick boom because I feel like
I've been sort of putting myself through
a film school so that I could direct my
first film this was a huge part of that
Rob Marshall is one of the best people
at making movie musicals I learned 50
things watching him work I will watch
John to direct the adaptation of in
Heights that will be the second year of
film school for me and then I will
direct my own film musical hopefully at
the end of next year with tick tick boom
and I've always I just think musical
stories are the hardest to get right but
when you get them right they're like
nothing else on earth it's the great
fortune of my life that I've been able
to get to work on them and I want to be
able to do that in film and on stage so
that's that's the goal who came back you
seemed hardly to have aged at all really
one David discusses a woman's age
Michael would have hoped I taught you
better
first of all Emily then what can I say
about this movie it's magical I loved
every second of it I have to say though
there's a ton of singing dancing and
both of you all get to sing and dance
but y'all got the easier path let's say
from the kids Emily were you watching on
set like I'm jealous are we like oh I'm
glad that I don't have to be sitting for
like Mary Poppins boot camp yeah we I
mean I have a bit of a fantasy about
doing a dance number well though I'm not
sure whether I could but I'd like to be
in a sort of feathers and sequins and
come down a white staircase in something
but they really heard yeah it was there
they're really hard task and they were
rehearsing you know for weeks and weeks
and weeks and there was no letter so but
we would be allowed in occasionally to
to watch their rehearsals and it was
that was amazing I mean it was that was
that was good enough for me just getting
to it
here in on the action from time to time
yeah um I will say Ben though you did
have a great song in a conversation that
was the first of many times that I cried
during the film and then my favorite
those with the kids when Joel does the
reprieve for where the loss things go
that was like oh and weeping and people
always say you know don't work with
animals don't work with kids what was it
like for you guys working with the kids
because again I think they have some of
the biggest emotional moments in the
movie yeah they were just wonderful
they were very grown-up when they yes
and very very professional more
professional possibly than we were and
really prepared and really really you
know enthusiastic they just loved being
there and tastic energy I've heard this
from adults that worked with kids like
sometimes there's unfortunately kid on
set you know you may let a swearword go
was there an adult's where where a John
Casey led a curse or go for the kids I
think that was was it was but we didn't
pay up we would have been we would have
been penniless and I think he was
Nathanial who was policing us yeah I
think he was the one point least he got
the more you felt you had to say it
figure they grew up fast
um last question this film is not a
Christmas movie quote unquote but it's
coming out in Christmas and for me it's
like a gift that keeps on giving
but Rotten Tomatoes we voted it's a
wonderful life the number one Christmas
movie of all time and so is that your
favorite Christmas movie if not what is
well the movie the other movie that was
a Mary Poppins was on throughout my
child our childhoods in England growing
up it was on every Christmas and every
holiday and so I watched it like 45
times before it even you know got to be
a grown-up but um the other movie that
was on every Christmas was the Great
Escape and that as 10 and that's of me I
associate that movie with with Christmas
and it's a brilliant film and it was my
mother's faith and I just I loved it I
think we need to change this up for
English people because you guys have
different ones
Muppets Christmas Carol classic for me
1992 or something
brilliant brilliant film been
undervalued I think so you've been off
filling the children's heads with stuff
and nonsense to be a child
robbed this movie it's magical I love it
so much
oh my goodness thank you so much and
thank you for your Mary Poppins inspired
outfit love it when looking at it though
the problem I feel with it is looking at
it the only thing I could think is this
is great I enjoyed it but how like how
did they make this look seamless how did
it make it look like it was not effort
and the scenes that I think I really
stood out from you yes triple alight
fantastic Wow and then also the last
scene with the balloons which I'm just
like how how did that work talk to you
about how you make those two scenes
happen cuz my head is wrapped
well it was three years in the making of
this whole film because it's an original
musical as you know so it was a whole
new story and all of that and those
specific scenes that you mentioned you
know triple life fantastic there were so
many layers to it but we had over two
months of rehearsal where we could
coordinate and choreograph I
choreographed this with Gianluca as well
so we could choreograph the lamplighters
and the principles and the children with
the new music and a new dance
arrangement and of course all the stunt
bikers all of that he had such careful
careful work and so we just plotted
through it very very carefully slowly
meticulously so you know the whole point
it should look completely effortless
like it's just happening but there were
so many pieces to it it was a very big
machine and a huge set and of course we
did a lot of location work in that
number too because it builds to that big
dance number and then then we're back on
Cherry Tree Lane but I have to say that
you know a production number like that
for example from me is comes from my
very gut you know I started as a dancer
and I was so excited and you know
honestly wanted desperately to create a
big musical production number like that
with a lot of athleticism for guys and
and so that was a dream come true and
then the balloon number you know a lot
of that was done on location with wires
of course that are removed eventually
but I wanted to try and be on location
for as much of it as possible even
though it's really complicated because I
want it to feel real I don't want to
look like a CGI event you know so I
really wanted to feel like it was all
happening and then we went into the
you know the green-screen space to do
some of the really high stuff but it was
all choreographed with wires very
complicated but so rewarding just you
know yeah so rewarding
nowhere else bring it back to like again
I love love the musical you've created
Chicago nine and they're all so
beautiful thank you one thing about this
one which you started in Chicago but
you've injected with this casting of
lin-manuel Miranda and some of the other
characters in this a whole new look of
Mary Poppins with you know
representation and talk about like you
know assembling this cast because if
there's a casting award it needs it okay
thank you so much well these were my
first choices across the board I mean I
honestly feel there was no one better on
the planet to play these roles but this
extraordinary cast and so I went after
the people that I really loved and I
have to say I have to love them in
person too you know because it's you're
creating a family you and you're doing
it for quite a long time so it has to be
wonderful people who all shared the same
spirit the spirit of this message of
this film which is to you know find that
childlike sensibility and and Wonder in
your life you know they all shared the
passion to send that message out to the
world so that was that was the key I
mean I will say even with the children I
will say we looked for hundreds and
hundreds of kids but I wanted real kids
that you really care for and it's about
I don't know that that rehearsal process
where you bond and create you know that
everyone's on the same film it was a
very special experience for all of us
and we were all reaching very high
you